killers of the flower moon is uh as
close as I can get to the perfect
theatrical experience it reminds me of
the films that were very special that I
saw in the 50s and 60s or not the same
kind of film but I'm saying the
theatrical experience of seeing a film
that has is an epic in a way and having
to be seen on a big screen with a large
audience it's really getting the
reactions from the people you can feel
around you and it all becomes one
experience that something is very
special that you may have at a concert
of some kind whether it's rock or
whether it's
classical or you may have an experience
in a theater watching a play that's 3 to
four hours long you all go through a
journey together as an audience so for
me this picture kills the flow Moon I
wanted to make it that special so that
you'd all be together watching this on a
big screen this spectacle but I think
also it's an interior spectacle and goes
deeper and I hope because you experience
it together in a theater I hope that it
stays with you and enriches your life
later on you keep thinking about it not
the you want to think about it but it
keeps coming back because it has maybe
some depth to
it